a hysterectomy is the surgical removal
of the uterus
when the ovaries and fallopian tubes are
also removed this is called a
hysterectomy with cell Pingo oo fer
ectomy a hysterectomy is done to treat
uterine cancer uterine fibroids
endometriosis uterine prolapse and other
gynecological conditions
when you arrive at the hospital for your
surgery an intravenous line will be
started if you are having an abdominal
hysterectomy your pubic and abdominal
area may be shaved hysterectomies may be
done under general or regional
anesthesia if you are receiving general
anesthesia you will be asleep for the
duration of the procedure and a
breathing tube will be temporarily
inserted through your mouth and into
your throat to help you breathe during
the operation a catheter will be placed
into your bladder to drain your urine
during surgery a hysterectomy takes
about one to three hours there are three
main ways to perform this surgery
through the abdomen through the vagina
or using a laparoscope to assist a
vaginal approach
for an abdominal hysterectomy your
surgeon will make an incision in your
lower abdomen
pull back the muscles to expose the
uterus
cut the ligaments and tissues holding
the uterus in place
and remove the uterus through the
abdominal incision
if your procedure includes a cell Pingo
0:04 ectomy your surgeon will remove the
ovaries and fallopian tubes in the same
manner
for a vaginal hysterectomy a weighted
speculum is inserted into your vagina to
stretch it and hold it open
your surgeon will make an internal
incision around the cervix cut the
ligaments and tissues holding the uterus
in place
and slide the uterus out through the
vagina
or laparoscopic assisted vaginal
hysterectomy your surgeon will create
several small incisions called ports in
your abdomen
carbon dioxide gas is then pumped
through one of the ports to puff up your
abdomen so its contents can be viewed
more easily
your surgeon will then insert a
laparoscope through one of the ports
images from its camera are projected
onto a video monitor in the operating
room watching on the monitor your
surgeon will slip specialized surgical
tools through the other ports and use
them to make an incision around the
cervix
cut the uterus free from its supporting
ligaments and tissues
and pass it out through the vagina a
laparoscope can also be used for a cell
Pingo oophorectomy finally your surgeon
will close the incisions on your abdomen
with stitches
in all three hysterectomy procedures the
top of the vagina is stitch closed and
gauze packing is placed in the vagina to
prevent excess bleeding
after your surgery you'll be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring the
catheter and the gauze packing will be
removed before you leave the hospital